Hello and welcome to this short
video, which will be an introduction to
one of the most exciting and
important projects of
2025. This, ladies and
gentlemen, is Crypto C
Vest.
OK, I'm Cryptosy. I have
developed and built
platforms such as Bidify and Vulcan
Launchpad. I am one of the
first members of the Cryptosy
Dow which fingers crossed will be
funding a portion of the development
of this project as it will be receiving a
portion of the fees for this project
but. What is the project, why does it
exist, and how we're going to build it?So
first of all, Kryptosi Vest will
be a customizable vesting
platform. The idea being that you
allow developers, or anyone really,
to vest their tokens and
have them released at varying
times and over
varying schedules now.
This is not anything that is new.
However, the way we're going to be doing
it is going to be unique. So the USPS,
the unique selling points for this
particular platform. Will be twofold.
First of all, we will have a price
triggering mechanism. This means that
devs can put their portion
of the supply into cryptosy vest
and it will not be released until the
project reaches a certain milestone.
The reason behind this thinking behind
this is that it will incentivize the
developers to get the price of
their particular token up to a certain.
Value before they can realise any of the
benefits. It means they will be working
for the community until such a point as
they have achieved their job for the
community, which will be getting their
hope into a particular price. Of course,
there is some game theory here which does
say that when they get it to that price,
what's to say that they won't just dump
it immediately? So will people. Or will
we always be selling just below that
price? Of course you can always.
Well not of course, but you will be able
to move your tokens
with invested project to. Higher
price, but you will not be able to move
them to a lower price. So what we
probably will see happen, as we haven't
seen that unfold yet, is we may see
developers move a small portion of their
or a big portion of their holdings at a
certain price up to another price
before their prices hit.
This will give the community the.
The knowledge that the developer is
still evolved and he's still
incentivizing himself. To keep on pushing
higher and higher, the second unique
selling point of Cryptosyfest will be the
fee structure. What we're going to do is
we're going to have currently, so this
this may be subject to change, but
currently we're looking to have a 5%
fee, which will be a flat fee
for all vested and will not be paid out
until such a time as the token has
reached its price target. Or is
being released if it's just a regular
linear or Cliff scheduling so
it won't only be price. You can have lock
up my tokens for six months or 12 months.
And then release them one month at a time
like regular schedule. It that's the
case, the fees don't get released until
the tokens are being released. The
fee structure will have
two components to it. There will be a
2.5% flat fee which
goes only.
To the cryptosy down. I'm not quite sure
what that special effect was just there
behind me, but there will be a 2.5%
fee which goes only to the cryptosyll
that will fund further developments by
the crypto sidel maintenance
for the. Bidify
platform for Vulcan, Launchpad for
Cryptosyves, for all of those things
moving forward. And there will also be a
2.5% fee which
is given to the vestin
partner, which means every
time a developer decides the vest, if he
does it through a vesting partners
website, that website will be
eligible to claim. Their
2.5% of the rested tokens upon
their release at the release time.
Because they will have a wallet which
will be given over at the time of the
vestin being made and then the vested
tokens will go to that wallet. So it's
really incentivizing partnerships down
the line. We're hoping to get
partnerships with the likes of Pump Dot
Fund, for example, so that when a
developer does launch a token and it goes
to the bonding curve, there's
automatically you know, that the
developer cannot rug you until the
token reaches a certain price. I think
this aligns very well. With
what the community of every
single token wants, they want to have
that that Peace of Mind.
OK, so let's move on.
OK, so we'll discuss what is
Cryptosyvest. Just want to go through
this brief presentation.
We do have place fill up graphics in here
which will give us an idea of the
kind of look that we're going to be going
for with the branding for
Kryptosi Vest. Of course, this
particular series will have maybe about
10 episodes where we will cover every
single step of the process of developing
this project. So this one. For Sale will
be an introduction. Then we're going to
cover things like putting a brand
together, putting A-Team together.
There'll be an episode for the logic
behind the project, which will go
into great detail of how the user
experience will be. Will be going to like
a step by step of what it will be like to
create a new vesting contract or to add
to a new vesting contract, or to withdraw
from a vesting contract at the correct
time, and how to search to see if your
token has a vesting. Tracked,
we're also going to have
episodes for the testing to show the
testing for the wire framing that'll be
enough for episode and for the design
will be another episode and we'll have an
episode for the smart contracts.
And the team if I have not already set.
So what are the the three main pillars
of the cryptos? US, we
want everything to be secure, which means
that we're going to have to have audited
smart contracts. We will more than
likely use AI auditing as our first
port of call. There are some very good
AI code auditing software. Schools
out there now on top of that we will
endeavour to have a proper,
shouldn't say proper, a more
full AI, not AI sorry,
and more full person LED on human
lead auditing
done by a top auditing firm that will
probably carry that out after we get
funding or grants from one of the EVM
systems. That or EVM networks that we go
with initially Cryptosyfest will be being
aimed at the. Networks, so you're looking
at Polygon base BNB,
but we do hope to
expand to Solana in our
second or third version.
And it's important that we start with the
EVMS because we want to start with that
added security and we feel like we could
produce a more secure product if we build
it on EVMS initially. Second to
that, we will go for the largest market
or the larger market, which will be
Solana. And finally, we'll go for the
growing markets, which will
be TSUI and Aptos.
So we want secure code, we want
transparent, transparent platforms. So
everything will be on the blockchain. All
of the vesting contracts will be on the
blockchain. Everything will be totally
transparent. You will know how much is
being invested. You will know who it is
being invested by. You will know who they
plan to pay the vesting out to because
you can FEST tokens and not be the
beneficiary of those tokens, you can.
Tokens and then say 1-6 finished, I want
it to go to the Dow or I want it to go to
this particular charity or I want to go
to this particular person. So you can
have that type of vest in
and the users will also know
how long it's been invested for and what
the actual terms of the release will also
be. So all of those things will be
covered in a transparent way by
Cryptosyvest. Finally, we want everything
to be user friendly. Through our Bidify
and Vulcanoid, what we have managed to do
is build amazingly user friendly
products. Products that are.
Very intuitive for people to use and are
not confusing. Currently the
scenario is that we know that there are
token lockups, but we don't really know
where to go to see these token lockups.
And even if we can see them, it's very
difficult for the average user to
understand the meaning of these total
lockups. What we may do, which is one of
the future goals, if even have.
A natural language AI agent plugged
into the platform so people could ask it
questions about the.
Vesting contracts that they're looking
at. For example they may ask when can
the dev crash the price and how much
influence would it have and the AI will
look and it will see that the devs only
got a small amount there and the rest
in level is very high. So they say well
the dev can't sell until the price
reaches very high and with its small
allocation that is vested you probably
won't be able to move the price that
much. Assuming that volumes grow.
So those are the things that we want. One
last thing on security which I failed to
mention is that we will have some. Form
of. Anti flash
system. So what we don't want is we don't
want somebody to be able to pump the
price within a block and then
withdraw their vested tokens
and thus rub pool the people
you can. This
slightly beyond the scope of this video
actually, but I'll go into it. You can
flash loan, borrow money for one block
and move the price of something and then.
Give that money back within that same
block. We definitely do not want that
to happen. So we will be looking into how
viable that is as a
vulnerability. It may not be that liable
and we will be making.
Every effort to mitigate that. So
let's move on. OK, so
we discussed the key, the
key advantages to Kurtosi Vest.
We've got some very early stage mockups
of what we think the dashboard will look
like. We
also. Want
to I guess highlight the multi chain
compatibility. So this
platform like the Crypto C,
like a bit of fire already has, will
cover quite a lot of Evms. We're planning
to have one or two at launch and
maybe about a month later.
9 or 10 and we want to go for the ones
with the biggest volume and try to help
them build out their own. It will
initially be I guess mean coin.
Sectors, but as mean coin
tokenomics are becoming more popular in
other projects, AI agents or things like
that, which aren't mean quads, that token
Onix or that token on the structure where
you have 1 billion tokens and you have
different entities receiving them at
launch. That structure needs itself
very well to also be used with
cryptosyvest.
The project is community driven, so
hopefully it will be built with funding
from Kurtosidou. I can't say it will be
for sure now because we haven't actually
put the proposal in at the time of making
this video, as this video will be a part
of the proposal.
And real time tracking as I already spoke
about. So what is the need for
Cryptosyvest? As we all know, developers
are rugging contracts. And
projects left, right and centre.
Often you will know, or some people will
know that they're going to get rugged and
they just buy anyway and hope that they
can jump out before the developer does.
Sometimes I guess they win, sometimes
they don't have in.
A absolute knowledge that the
developer cannot rug with this particular
amount of his coins is or
tokens is a huge advantage
for the user and I think it's something
that developers will also want to
leverage. We have to discuss a
caveat, which will be that just
because the developer labels this
as a developer wallet or that was the
wallet that created the token, it doesn't
mean that developer or a cabal around
him. Not own other tokens in other
places, in other wallets that he has not
rested. So this does not make everything
absolutely foolproof. It is just yet
enough a signal or another tool that
people can use both to ensure trust,
inspire trust from both ways.
So for the community members to get trust
on their developer and for the developer
to inspire trust in themselves, there are
tools like bubble maps. Which
will help you to.
See or identify if
other entities have got clusters of large
tokens and I guess we will cover
that in a a
later episode and hopefully we can get a
partnership with them as well. We will
definitely try.
Also, another reason that we need it is
that there isn't a robust and user
friendly platform for vesting, so it
really needs to be done. It's a part of
the inner structure that doesn't quite
yet exist and especially
hasn't been incentivized. OK,
so who are the builders? I am Fritosi, I
am the project manager I
guess and. I
can't claim the idea for myself because
it's an idea that has existed. I've we've
just. Found some ways to improve upon
the idea. Currently the developer who
we will be tasking with building this
will be a Snowman or Bino as he's
also known. He was one of the
developers in Bitter 5 in its early
stages. So although he did not develop
the smart contracts behind Bidify, he did
improve them. He added a buy it
now system. And
he added, he's added quite a few things,
but we do have a Meet the developer Park
video on this channel with Snowman
or Bino. So I will put a link to that in
the description or you can just search
the channel, Smartreach channel and you
will find it. Biden has got a a
long history of working with us. He's
worked with us on quite a few things. So
we're quite sure he will be able
to pull this one off.
And if he can't, we have other developers
in the wings waiting to pick up where he
left off. But we're confident he can
build it. Early suggestions say
that the development of the
platform. Altogether will take possibly
around two months, so we should be
able to finish it in three
good sprints. I would say each Sprint.
Maybe last in two weeks.
So we should be able to to do that.
I think that's it with Barno.
Sorry. Let's move on. OK, so what's our
path to success? So this is a very
loosely written
road map.
So we plan to launch Q
12025. We want to be integrated
with the lead the the leading blockchain
networks, the top EVM chains.
We really want to be with Solana as well,
but it's a completely different
technology. Solana is to a complete
different technology to the EVM so.
We can't as easily port from
EVM to Solana as we can from EVM
to another EVM. So we will start with the
EVM as overall it's possibly
slightly more market share
expansion or functional features,
features or functionality. At the end of
this show, I will speak briefly
to what features our
functionality we are planning to add in
the future. Partnerships with top
blockchain projects. We will be working
on that as soon as possible. This video
will also serve as.
A call to action for grant
teams and.
Other such funding methods which we will
be applying for on the top ten
Evms that we are planning to build on.
So if we do get those grants or that
funding, what it also hopefully will
do is it will lead us to get connections
to the other top projects on those
networks. Which will
enhance our ability to get
partnerships.
Finally, we want to have continued
development and innovation similar
to Bidify and Vulcan Launchpad once it's
built. That's only the beginning. The
plan is to keep it ahead of the game, to
keep it up to date with the
the growing, I
guess, philosophies and
ethos and functionality.
Behind crypto. So
that's how a new state based road map. Of
course the road maps are always
fluent and I expect this road map
to become more fleshed out over time
with time scales of when we plan to do
these things. But now is a little bit too
early to say, OK, so how
are we going to ensure trust and safety?
We touched on it before, so I'll keep it
brief. We want auditable smart contracts.
Auditable and verified, that's.
I want the beauties of the EVM. You'll be
able to see what exactly is you are
working with and you can audit those
contracts yourself if you want to, but
we will audit them too. Anti
flash mechanisms, how those will work at
the moment is that the price will need to
remain above a certain level for a
certain length of time, so.
We're thinking somewhere between 24
hours to one week should be
around the time that price should stay
above a level before. Release is
eligible and people can activate it. Once
you activate release, which should be be
which should be possible from any wallet.
So it's not only the people who are old
tokens that can activate the release. It
should be anybody that can activate the
release of these tokens. And we
will have regular audits. The reason why
we'll have regular audits is because
we'll be having regular updates to the
code base. Every time you have an update,
you potentially introduce new
vulnerabilities. Also, there are new
vulnerabilities being found every day.
So we will need to have regular audits.
By regular I mean.
Every six to 12 months, assuming there
are no changes to
the code base. Otherwise, anytime we make
relevant or sizable changes to the code
base, we should have another audit.
OK. And that is it. So yeah,
join us in revolutionising the blockchain
and just making vesting
a more.
Accessible and useful tool
for everybody involved. What
I want to do, briefly is take you behind
the scenes. So here's our.
Working Document. This is a document that
we work within as a team.
We touch on, so we've got all of our
dolls lined up just so that we're all on
the same page. We've got all of our goals
lined up and the things that are the most
important. Oh, one thing I did touch on
was the escape hatch, which will
allow cryptosy Dow
members to remove the whole
funds of any particular.
Investing contract should that contract
for whatever reason no longer be fit for
purpose? So if a developer
accidentally says I want my token to
reach. trillion, when
really they meant I wanted to reach 1
billion. Then we should be able to
remove those funds to the
cryptosyde out, and then from there send
them to whoever needs them. That
will come with a lot of bureaucracy. So
chances are if you're a small project and
you've made that mistake, it's going to
be too bad, too sad. But that is one of
the things that happens within blockchain
anyway. We had the Dow. We've had things
like that we've had. Accidental lockups
like we did on, I want to say parity.
Umm. And I've done it myself,
so it does happen where you do lock
things up. You got to take your time. If
you don't, we do have an escape hatch,
which will be like a worst case scenario
system. That
does obviously introduce its own issues,
so the deployment of
this escape hatch will be I guess.
Possibly optional. So possibly if you
don't want to have the escape hatch, you
could possibly set up your existing
contract without it being there and then.
If you do it wrong or something gets
locked in that testing contract, then
you're on your own. So I think that makes
sense actually.
Specification, vesting schedules, price
base, audited smart contracts,
we discussed the the fees
already and our milestones. We
also discussed I think maybe this Q
3 might be moved forward to Q2,
possibly even Q1 if we can, if we can
ship it in time. And then we have our our
steps that will that will go through
each step will be another episode. So
create a team and the brand. Create a
logic document, create a wireframes,
create a front end, design
smart contracts, back end, integrate,
fully testing, launch and finally future
features NFT beneficiaries.
Instead of just your wallet being
thing, you want it being tracked
by the smart pun tracks
that have the resting tokens. You may get
an NFT. What that will mean is that you
can trade your vested token so. I may
have 1,000,000 vested
cryptosy coins that I can only release
when it reaches $1.00, but I may be able
to sell that share for $100
tosomebody who believes that
we will reach that price more than I
believe I reach that price. So that
secondary market would be extremely
interesting. So we are considering a
building around that it it will also
possibly provide another income source if
there is. A Some sort of tax
on the. Selling of
the NFTS from one person to another.
AI support I touched on monitor alerts
would also be useful. So you may get a
text message or a Telegram message or an
e-mail to say that your
token is near its resting target.
It would be a lovely thing, like a
celebration time. I'm about to be able
to release some of my tokens. Vested
liquidity will be, I guess, where
we take the vested tokens.
And we put them into.
Liquidity pool and we then have the
rewards from that liquidity pool be
shared amongst all the people who have
vested tokens, which would incentivise
your community to come vest with you
because they will then benefit from the
trading fees as well as
strengthening the tokenomics of their
project. And then
finally a faith-based
audit. It's important
that we build something that uses
worldwide can get involved in. Which
means it has to adhere to their
their view of the world. And we have had
some projects which we have decided not
to build which. Impinge on
certain people's faiths. So we're going
to audit that. Not to say that if it
doesn't align with a certain person's
faith that we won't build it, but just
that we're on top of that and we
make sure that our users are also on top
of that. So we can say this is
OK for you to use as there are.
Not
overwhelmingly high interest
being earned or usury or any of these
other sorts of things that can turn up in
this minefield of a world we have
now where people from all over the world
are expected to use the same tools. So
I've been crypto. See, this has been your
introduction to Cryptosyvest.
I hope you have understood exactly what
it is we are planning to do. To put it
into a nutshell, in case you haven't, is.
Develop underwater token. Developer
locks up a certain amount of token.
Developer can only take the token back
when the project reaches a certain price.
Developer then is super incentivized for
the token to reach a certain price and he
cannot take his ball and leave. He can
leave if he wants to, but if he does, he
is leaving that
reward in the.
In the vesting project, if the project
dies, his portion of it dies with it.
When we have NFTS, the developer will
get an NFT, which makes the community
take over of any type much
more viable. The developer
can then give the NFT to whoever decides
to take over a project, and if they trust
that developer not hiding another massive
amount of tokens elsewhere, which they
can verify to a degree by using bubble
maps, they can at least mitigate it. Then
they may buy the dev rights off of
that guy and get the NFT. And then when I
had to reach a certain light, then this
new death can claim his
rewards. That is, in a nutshell,
what Cryptosy Rest will be doing. We are
going to be building this regardless. So
if you're watching this video because of
a grant and you're considering whether or
not to allow the
grant. We're
kind of oxygen out of courtesy. We're
already building on networks where we are
free to build anyway, so we are going to
deploy on the network anyway. Regardless
of whether or not you offer the grant, of
course the grant will be nice. It will
help us to add bells and whistles. We can
pay for marketing or we can pay to
have business developers reach out to
other projects within that ecosystem.
And also it's, it's more of a
sign that you want us on the
network, you want this product on the
network and we go
to where we are loved. As
humans, we just do so.
I've been crypto see you have been
beautiful and hopefully
I will see you in the next episode where
we will discuss the brand
and everything around that, which at
this moment of time is actually complete.
And I think we can
see the logo up here just as a
here's one we produced earlier. And
this is going to be the the look
of the site or the look of the brand.
So facts watching and I will see
you in the next one please.